a dimension is a way of measuring one of
two things right
either you contain an object or what we
call this is a technical word by the way
a space right so dimensions a way of
measuring an object or a space okay now
this word space it has a very technical
video which I'm about to explain in a
second all it means is if you've got a
space you can move around in some way
okay and you can move on different
another sort of synonym for axis is
direction but since a few years ago with
a certain boy band appeared I try to say
that word Direction is living as you see
believe me it gets worse okay so a
direction that I can move you all right
now let's draw ourselves a table to try
and unpack in sort of concrete terms
what these dimensions are what we're
trying to think about is different kinds
of objects or spaces that have different
kinds of dimensions right and there are
four that you are familiar with on sort
of a daily basis so our headings are
dimensions and this is going to be just
it's just going to be a number okay
the second one is okay what did the
directions look like okay so you can use
color directions directions and then
what we're going to have on the end is
what do you name an object in this in
this space okay so now for reasons that
we come fear in a moment I'm gonna leave
that first row we leave it like it's a
bit strange we'll come back to it we're
going to this first one what happens
when you have an object
or space it has one dimension right it
means you have one axis right so for
instance I could say left and right left
and right that's a single direction that
you can move in okay a single axis so
what does it look like it looks
something like this left right that's
what a one-dimensional object or a one
dimensional space looks like now it goes
on forever and we have a name for this
right what do you call such an object X
it's just a wine right now we could
label it further and give it says called
the x axis first thing at the moment
that doesn't make all that much sense
because I don't have any other axes so I
don't need to name them I'm just gonna
call it the wine right and we have this
in you know when you first learn about
integers and stuff we have the number
wine okay this way you can get that way
all right still familiar ground if we
add a dimension okay I wanna retain this
left-right axis of movement that I had
before that's right but if I want a
second dimension I need a second
direction that I can move it so of
course you've seen this before
we have uptown now Rene Descartes
remains a French guy very smart he was
the first person to do a lot of rigorous
work with understanding this kind of
coordinate system which is why this kind
of shape at least when we load that it
bears his name what do you call this
thing we call it the Cartesian plane
right it's a it's a space that's got two
dimensions so you can't just call it
plane it doesn't have to be Cartesian
right I haven't put Nick's in Y on it
but that's this idea I've got two
directions I can review or another way I
can say it is I can
we define anywhere in this space with
two numbers an x and y in exactly the
same way that I can uniquely define
anywhere in this space with just one no
because it's one-dimensional right so as
soon as I say let you I say okay I'm at
zero you don't need any more information
to know where I am okay but if I said
yeah I'm at zero that's not enough
information I could be anywhere in this
vertical line you need a second number a
second coordinate all right
still familiar in fact the world we have
it three dimensions we're going to take
the same directions we already have
we're just going to add one more right
so I've got op down I don't go on left
right now this is where the whiteboard
and your book is going to fail us at the
moment because what we're drawing on is
a plane right we're drawing on a
two-dimensional space I've got the board
you've got the book okay so
unfortunately we can't draw a real
three-dimensional space but we can
pretend to write how would you draw it
yeah diagonally you'd put another axis
here right so let's do that and if you
kind of squint at it
you can kind of imagine what it's doing
is it's going back and forth back and
forth I guess you'd say like out of your
page or further down into your hook okay
so I'm going to call this axis back and
forth by the way as hazards mentioned
before if we want to name these things
right this will just be X this one would
be X and y in a bit of a confusing thing
we tend to say okay well we'll have X
and then Y and this would be Z coming
out of the page but sometimes then is
drawing a different orientation going up
and down anyhow three different axes now
I don't you like this word that was
mentioned before it wasn't what I
originally chose but I like it because
it's um it says the same I do in a
different way I don't have to just think
about movement I can also think about
like how far away am i how big is that
number that's what magnitude means okay
what do we call this thing we call this
evolving you you're used to thinking of
that is like oh how much you know how
much space does this thing take on all
right well what it really means is that
whole space in there I can review three
dimensions now here's why I left off
that first row right these dimensions
we're familiar with and we work with
them all the time at least so when
you've got one two and three that kind
of implies a zero doesn't it now what
would that mean right that means I can't
move anywhere right I can't move up down
left right back and forth can you move
this way or just in one direction see I
avoid
I was doing so well I can't move
anywhere so what does that thing look
like there is just a dot out technical
name for dots in mathematics of course
our points so point has no dimensions
you can't go anywhere right